North Korea's nuclear program is moving ahead despite years of international sanctions.
Newly confirmed Secretary of State John Kerry said this week...
...that North Korean nuclear tests only increase the potential for conflict.
And the people of North Korea are starving.
They desperately need to become more open and connected to the world...
...instead of harboring some of the worst gulags in the world...
...where people are tortured and forced labor...
State Department spokeswoman Victoria Nuland said the US...
...will make sure last month's Security Council resolution, broadening sanctions...
...against Pyongyang for its nuclear weapons program, will be enforced.
We can ensure that that's not just a piece of paper,...
...that those sanctions are implemented around the international community.
But Georgetown University professor Balbina Hwang says...
...this approach doesn't sway North Korea's leaders.
That only works if the regime views integration into the international community as a positive goal.
The problem is North Korea has never wanted to join the international community.
North Korea won't even be deterred by threatened penalties from China,...
...its main source of food and fuel, she says.
It will basically be calling China's bluff.
At a time of domestic unrest in China and a slowing economy,...
...Beijing views the test as a destabilizing factor....
...says Professor Jin Canrong of the Renmin University of China.
There were too many problems for the leadership.
They do not want to have problems abroad.
Experts say the North Korean test will make it more difficult to halt Iran's nuclear program...
...because the two nations share technology.
Jerome Socolovsky, VOA News, Washington.